okay
here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to
yo
absolutely
favorite podcast
welcome back
[Music]
the golden voice is back
uh welcome back to ripping with griffin
today i want to discuss the nfl
i want to do a little bitching with
griffin it's my favorite thing to do and
i want to talk about
doom
and i want to talk about murder in the
building oh it was good i also traveled
to um where do i go this week i was in
arlington washington this week
i did the draft house and that was great
but just once again welcome back
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i think we went overboard with the
woo-woos today
uh we had a little overboard
okay first up as you know i like to use
different pictures when i'm here by
myself and today i think i got i i may
have the person wrong but i hope i don't
but this was sent in by mr will peacock
for so for a little while the episode
we're in his living room area i guess
i'm not sure but it's a nice looking
thing he's got a fireplace you know so
uh so we're we're out here in will's
place right now so i hope that is who it
is so thanks will for sending in the
picture and if you'd like to send in a
picture uh you know send it to you can
send it to my instagram or you can email
email me at eric eric griffin.com but
make sure you make sure it's like the
horizontal you know what i mean so it
could fit on the screen a lot of people
are sending me pictures that are like
you know you know the uh the other way
and the dimensions can't fit so i gotta
crop it so just crop it for me you know
use some common sense
and when you send a picture so
if you'd like to send a picture send
that out so
for a portion of the podcast will be in
wills
but i still also really enjoy um
i also want to get back to i miss
i miss mexico so i also want to have i
want to bring rachel back on
you know because we really had a good
time out in mexico so this is actually a
good setting too so
for a portion of the podcast most of
it's going to be this one but for the
start here let's get back to my man will
peacock's living room all right so thank
you and welcome to roofing with griffin
uh as always please uh i'm on twitch
daily
uh so make sure you check me out there
on twitch
that is
errorgriffingaming on twitch so that's
still going strong so appreciate that
thank you very much for you know the
support i get there
um so that is what it is so first um i
just got back from arlington washington
i had this great view from my hotel room
of the pentagon and it was just like so
bizarre i mean i literally opened my
window i should have taken why didn't i
take a picture of that i really should
have taken a picture that showed you
guys what i was talking about
you know you forget you know sometimes
you just live life you don't always want
to record life you know so and i
actually don't think there's anything
wrong with that too like not everything
needs to go on the internet not
everything you need to share i lived
that i had that experience it was my own
i was just sitting in a chair looking
out and it was like this great view of
the pentagon and i just it just it
reminded me to i thought back to 911 and
i thought back to like
like how like this must have been what a
scene that must have been in this area
and you know how things change how
resilient we are as human beings how we
are
how resilient we are as united states
citizens you know
all the things that we've gone through
in the past you know 100 years and here
we are dealing with another big thing
and we're surviving we're doing it so so
i had a great view of that and that was
great uh that area was pretty nice i
don't know if you guys if you know about
my other podcast gen degen with matthew
espinoza uh make sure you know you check
that one out too we're trying to build
that one it's a fun little concept you
know it's just about i'm you know i'm an
old guy he's a young guy and we're
trying and we're talking about the
different generations and we bring
people on and we discuss discuss that
kind of stuff and it's actually pretty
interesting conversation so last episode
was with megan traynor and her brother
ryan traynor and we talked about therapy
and all this kind of stuff so make sure
you guys check that out but matthew's
family is from that area so his mom and
dad came to the show
and then they uh picked me up
uh you know the day i'm leaving to take
me to the airport so but they made me a
home-cooked breakfast and they lived in
this like really quaint part of
washington virginia area
um
it was just this like like in the sticks
a little bit you know but it was just
like a beautiful area they had like this
five acres and they had the house that
the dad built himself so he was very
proud of his house you know he's walking
around like i built this fireplace and
he was like you know showing me it was
he was so proud of it and it's like
that's you know that's that's such a
such a great thing when you see somebody
make something and they're really proud
of it but it was just really nice to see
like what a what an all-american family
even though he's he wasn't born if dad
wasn't actually born in the united
states but it was like this is an
example of the american dream which we
don't just we don't talk about enough we
don't we don't remember that that was
the thing you know you come to america
from some other country if you did and
then you you know you built you you
build yourself up and you know you with
what however way you can and then you
know you live the dream later you have a
bunch of kids they have four kids and
they you know they lived a great life
and they're still doing it right now so
with all the kids out of the house you
know and so
it was good to see you know it just
reminded me of um and you know the other
thing that was good about it too is that
that
his dad mom and dad have a big age
difference
and it's actually the same age
difference as rachel and i and i saw how
they ended up and i see their life and i
it just really gave me even some more
faith and joy and thinking about like
moving forward in my life with rachel
you know uh
and you know and that's why i'm still
you know and i don't know all you old
all you people out there like over 40
who's you know starting a new life you
know just getting in relationships or
getting married or don't have kids yet
there's still hope you know and it's
like that's what i'm trying to i've
talked about this before but it's about
like you know taking care of yourself
you know so that's why i'm trying to
like
eat better and work out and you know get
get myself in shape so i can live
another however many years and have this
whole other life with like you know with
rachel and kids and all that kind of
stuff so
you know it's it was good it was good to
see that that's really the reason why i
wanted to talk about
seeing that and just seeing you know oh
like i i envision myself later in life
and this is what it'll be like you know
so you know it was it was it was fun to
see and they were really nice people so
kudos to
the espinoza clan
really appreciate that
um
what else is going on uh but anyway like
i say um it was uh really fun to see
um
it was really fun to see
you know his parents and you know and
his brother came to the to the show too
so
it was it was nice to be out there
anyway and and all the shows were good
and also saw my cousin my shout out to
my cousin alyssa she came to the show
and it was oh it's always good to catch
up with her you know i don't have a lot
of family i don't have a lot of close
family and she's one of my
that's just
you know she's one of my class it's her
it's angelique my other cousin in new
york who i saw when i went to new york
and alyssa they're like my two closest
blood relatives that you know
and i always i have to remember that
that you know you always forget that you
have family because they don't live near
me it's not like i have that instant
like hey can you pick me up from this or
you know we're not running errands for
each other because you know we don't see
each other all the time but when you're
with them it's a good reminder of like
oh yeah this is a really close
relationship so i always say to you
people out there keep in touch keep in
contact with your loved ones you know
if you have some even if you have a big
family even if you have a big family i'm
sure there's like a few people that you
like these are like
your favorites
you know what i mean like easy for me to
have favorites because i don't have a
big family i don't have a family that
like we keep in contact so the ones i do
keep in contact i'm like oh these are my
favorites but there are some people that
you have like a huge family and then
maybe you you know you take it for
granted so like whoever you you are like
you know keep in contact you know stay
close you know stay close because you
never know when all when it'll all
go away you know what i mean
so keep keep a lookout for that in your
lives people so uh so that was fun so
again shout out to my cousin for for
seeing her and in the shows and it was
the arlington draft house in uh in
arlington it was they were very nice it
was actually a very nice venue
the shows for the every single show was
was pretty good you know they were
pretty good it was great it was great
shows actually i only had one issue
again once again there's some kind of
pattern where you but this wasn't like a
whole thing like this this chick just
like she she just walked out she just
said something to me because my cousin
like when she comes to my shows she
always says she knows how it's going
based off like the conversation in the
women's bathroom
so she's in the women's bathroom because
the women are in there just like oh i
like oh he's funny or whatever or
somebody might be like i don't like him
i can't believe he's talking about what
he's talking about you know so there was
one person like that and my cousin was
like uh oh this is gonna be she's gonna
be one of those and sure enough as she
walked out she was like you know what
you're sexist you know that she just
walked off you know what i mean but you
know
i don't want to obsess over this one
person but it seems like there's a
pattern for me or there's always one
that's like that because everyone else
seemed to have a great time because
their little picture lines long and you
know all these couples you know male
female you know all females are coming
and taking pictures and they're like oh
my god you were so funny i loved it but
you know it's crazy how we obsess over
the one person that we didn't get to but
you know it is what it is for the most
part it was all great shows so i think
that and you know i'm also guys i've
been on king in the sting a lot uh so
thanks to the king and the sting uh
people
you know the king in this thing uh what
do you call it um fan base
there is a very small toxic
people and they're always on the
instagram they're always in every time
they put instagram there's like these
toxic people that like they don't have
anything positive to say about the show
it's just all negativity towards me
you know it really it really is like it
really is strange the amount of hate
like it's like the amount of hate coming
from like six people
is so
toxic and you just go damn like what did
i date your mom or something you know
what i mean like it's so weird
but um i
it doesn't really bother me
uh it was the only reason why i'm
bringing this up and talking about it is
i just want to thank actually the real
fans because they come to the show
like so
i do appreciate those that fan base
who's one listening to my podcast now
and two who are actually coming out to
the show because they are the first ones
to tell me they come right up to me when
they're taking pictures like yo man love
you on king of the sting i came here
from king and sting and you know and i
go oh okay so like you know what and i
have to and i realized those are the
important people you know like the
internet's not real
that's you know and i was reminded of
that this weekend
i was reminded of these like
these sad
pathetic trolls who only want to put out
negativity
i'm reminded that they're sad pathetic
trolls
and the people that actually care that
put money in my pocket the people that
you know remind me that i am appreciated
for what i do
those people make a real difference and
a real impact in my life and i want to
take the time to thank those people and
also not even forgetting all of you
ryder died dogs that have been on the
river we're griffin trained from the
very beginning
i don't say thank you enough to you guys
too because you know
think of like
you know think of your fan base as just
a black canvas or a dark room okay it's
a dark room or a dark canvas and if you
put one little red light
in a dark room it's all you see
and you forget that this room is also
filled with something else but it's that
one little light and that's the
negativity you know so sometimes it's
hard to not focus on that one dot when
you have to remember that how the vast
everything else is so this is my shout
out to you guys
thank you uh you know let me just get
this thing in mic
[Music]
all right so that's a thank you song to
you guys so thanks for being here
okay so what we uh don't haven't had a
lot of
officially what's my brand y'all always
talking about i complain too much what's
my brand bitching with griffin you know
i this is why you're here if you don't
like it i don't need you to tell me like
you always complaining because that's
what i do [ __ ] that's what i do if you
don't like it
turn it off go to another podcast
there's like six million of them okay
but this is what we do here so i do have
something
that i legit wanna [ __ ] about and once
again before i do that though i wanna
thank will peacock thanks will for your
picture of your living room you know but
i miss mexico and i want to go back to
this one so we're here in uh this was in
cabo at the adam devine wedding and
there is the beautiful rachel
for the rest of the podcast
um so this is something i want to [ __ ]
about i know look it is what it is guys
i i ain't gonna apologize for it okay so
i fly united airlines all right now
i always tell people this if you travel
and if you think you're gonna travel
like like maybe more than five times in
a year you really should pick an airline
and stick with it no matter what the
cost of the thing is because getting
status on the airline is important it
actually very beneficial so as a comic
as someone that travels almost every
weekend it is important for me to have
status on an airline now you try to get
status on all the airlines but it's hard
to do that because they want you to have
a certain amount of miles a certain
amount of money spent they've really
changed it you should just be like that
the airline miles you fly but then it
was unfair for people that flying from
the west coast like if you're on the
west coast you're always going to get a
lot of miles because to fly from you
know california is you know it's always
going to be two thousand three thousand
four thousand miles to get across the
country or whatever the flight you know
if you have connecting flights that take
you you know you get a lot of miles that
way so they changed it they had some
kind of algorithm that they do you know
and you have to get this amount of miles
and then they made it so oh you also
have to spend this amount of money so
for a time on united airlines it was
like well before the pandemic because
they changed it they they're giving you
a break now but before it was like
you the best status you want to get is
1k because they have this one called
global services and the [ __ ] is like
fight club you know it's like nobody
talks about it you don't know how to get
in it i don't even know how global solar
services work it's something like
you know it's some secret society man
it's some illuminati stuff over the
united airlines so but before the
pandemic it used to be you had now check
this out
you had to fly
a hundred thousand miles
plus spend
twelve thousand dollars
in a year to get 1k status
you know with flights being like you
know between five and six hundred
dollars depending on where you're gonna
because a lot of flights are exp you
know that's a lot okay so a hundred
thousand
and then to be 1k
all right so they changed this thing
about so they have pre-boarding and you
hear comics do this dumb joke all the
time about the pre-boarding and all the
things but on united the pre-boarding
goes like this
it goes
people with disabilities
okay
i'll give you that one all right people
with disabilities it takes them a while
i don't understand why they don't just
do them last but then you had to put the
bags and everything okay so you let the
people with disabilities go on first
boom
second
active military
i'm all for it thank you for your
service you know what you're doing a lot
for the country you're risking your life
you know you know what i'm saying you're
on the front lines whatever it is i get
that one too let's let's give them
something you know since we can't give
them proper health care since we can't
give them you know the airlines are at
least like you know what military you
get get some first class status and you
get to go on the plane early
okay
then they do this magical global
services and it's rarely that you even
see somebody get on the plane with
global services flights they're
especially depending on where you are
too i travel all over the country but
when i see a global service person i'm
always looking at i'm like why the hell
that person got global services i don't
i don't get it because it's invite only
and it's like really spelled like global
services it's like
they'll actually sometimes they'll pick
you up at the flight like you'll get off
the plane and get into a a car and then
they'll drive you to your connection
flight they have these like really like
you know you always get to upgrade you
know it's like the global services has a
lot of like hidden perks and it's like
that's why i don't know how to get into
it but 1k is the one underneath that and
1k is pretty good too because now you
get this
you know what 1k you get like early
upgrades uh you know you like one time i
was in germany and i missed my flight so
because i was 1k they got me on another
flight without any cost and it wasn't
you know there's any problem and then
even the lady told me it's like you're
lucky you're 1k because she had an
attitude problem so you get a lot of
stuff with 1k all right
okay so they had the boarding so the
global services now here's where i'm
gonna start bitching okay here's the
next one that they let on the plane all
right before 1k
1k is last of the pre-boarding you know
who they let on before 1k
people with kids under 2 years old
what
excuse me
first of all
you ain't even supposed to be traveling
with little kids like that like that's
like what are you doing you've lost the
privilege to like be in regular society
when you've decided to have a little kid
you if you this better be an emergency
while you traveling with this kid babies
crying on the plane kids acting up it's
like it's such a hassle i see you going
through this hassle you you made this
choice to travel with this kid you
shouldn't get no extra perks like
they're letting like here's my problem
with it so you could buy you could have
a a two-year-old and you bought the
cheapest ticket possible you you never
fly this airline you're not even loyal
to the airline you just got the cheapest
ticket and you get to get on the plane
before the people that make they have to
spend twelve thousand dollars and fly a
hundred thousand miles you letting the
people with babies get on the plane
before me
i got a problem with it yep i'm bougie
like that yup i'm elitist like that when
it comes to my airline status i don't
know why the hell they allowing people
with kids who ain't even supposed to be
traveling with kids to get on the plane
before me i got a problem with the
united airlines i got a problem with it
okay that i'm just putting out there
they should be last okay we still you
still get a they still getting on before
all the other riff raff all right they
still getting special but why are you
letting them go on before your 1k
1k is the highest level you can achieve
besides this
mythical global service and you you
treating us like what like like that for
that like go all the way with it okay
hey first world problems but that's what
i do i [ __ ] about a lot of stuff
some small things big things things that
don't mean nothing to most people but
that's what
so
that ends the [ __ ] regret segment
about that
[ __ ] piss me off man
okay
i know some of you right now are rolling
your eyes and you know i don't care you
know what i mean you don't know me
that's what i [ __ ] about okay now let's
talk about
the nfl all right the nfl season is in
full swing right now my fantasy football
team is doing good my main one is doing
great i love it my other one i got it i
got into a league with the eric griffin
gaming community but like i care about
it but it's so fresh and new you know
like i didn't change my lineup this week
and so i lost to a one of these
i can't stand him i'm gonna get a shout
out to jeff jeff beat me fair and square
but i didn't change two people in my
lineup and so now
you know i lost that game because i was
on a plane i was flying home from
washington and then like last second the
the the tight end for the writers was
out
anyways
so nfl season is really good this year
you know i really i'm having a good time
watching i got nfl red zone off i use
youtube tv so i get nfl red zone as a
part of that package and i love watching
nfl red zone but there's so many good
teams good stories that are going on in
the nfl this season that i love it man
like if you look at the um if you look
at the records right now
you know you look at the records man you
look at you know the afc you know we got
the bills at 4 and 2. the raiders the
raiders after all that stuff with gruden
they're still five and two atop of the
afc west which at one point we thought
was the best uh division in football but
it turns out it might not be uh you know
because you got the raiders the chargers
you know this is all like like raiders
are always going to be the la raiders to
me so it's like the raiders you know
you know the raiders are raiders from my
childhood so that's why i support them
even though when they in las vegas but
you know you got the chargers and then
like you know then you go to look at the
bengals like the bengals uh they beat
the breaks off the ravens last night so
they're five and two ravens five and two
and then you got the titans who are five
and two they're a great team right and i
mean i can't wait for the nfl playoffs
man like it's going to be really wait
what's going on here i'm trying to okay
here we go then you go to the uh nfc
then you got the nfc then you got like
the cowboys which i'm not a cowboys fan
and i can't stand cowboys fans but
they're five and one the cardinals are
seven and oh rams boom boom boom boom
boom i'm really supporting the rams this
year i got my rams hat on rams are six
and one love that they're playing great
i mean i can't wait to play and then the
packers after all that drama and off
scene with with the packers and all that
stuff that happened like where they got
beat up game one and there was this
whole thing like oh man
why you know is this gonna be a
distraction all year they're six and one
then you got the returning champs the
buccaneers are six and one you know so
this i mean you got there's going to be
a really good team that is not going to
make the playoffs this year and in the
playoffs are going to be matchups of all
teams i think that have a chance to win
the super bowl that means i think this
year is going to be the best playoff
uh that's going to be the best playoffs
we've had in a really long time where
every single game is super competitive
even that wild card game you know
you know who who knows man who knows
like
who could like anybody any of these
teams that i mentioned has a legit
chance
to make the super bowl because every
time every week other than the cardinals
who haven't let us down yet in terms of
like they have no losses but every
single one of these teams you go oh man
they're rolling this is the team then
they get a loss and you go uh oh wait a
minute because that's what happened with
the um ravens like the ravens were
rolling and rolling and then they got
the brakes beat off of them
by uh tennessee last night so then
you're just like what like so now who's
the best team so i'm just uh i wanted to
give a second to uh give a shout out to
the nfl
and how fun it is to watch this year you
know and keep your uh keep your head
keep keep a lookout for when these
playoffs come in there's gonna be some
good stuff going on here in the playoffs
yeah
all right where are we at now
okay so now i want to talk about i want
to do some reviews um
it might be a short episode this week
but i want to talk i want to review some
stuff now um
this i i saw this show and it's on
hulu
and it's called only murders in the
building
and that's what it's on hulu it's with
steve martin
martin short
and you can't see her because i'm
blocking her and there she is selena
gomez what's up girl
you have to
you have to you have to be watching to
see what i just did but anyways
only murders in the building uh it's on
hulu um am i gonna sp i'm not gonna
spoil anything so don't worry there's no
spoiler alerts right now
um let me uh i'm a one-man show so i'm
looking it up right now so i can also
show some stuff here only murders in the
building uh this is a really funny show
man
i haven't laughed out loud
at a show in a while
i mean just legit
just legit laugh out loud and that's and
i've done and i got to tell you martin
so for you young people like you don't
even know who martin short is man
but this dude is so the guy in the
middle and he's just a legend i think
steve martin and martin short are both
in their 80s like they're like they're
old guys but they're spry you know they
got themselves looking you know looking
good and it is just really fantastic
show
and martin short man they're giving him
the lines that just make you laugh out
loud man
and so the show's about
these three
people that live in this sort of upscale
new york apartment that you apartment
place okay
like you know like it would be
equivalent to like a condominium or
something like that but in new york you
know people buy apartments in new york
you know you you
you own you own stuff or or it's okay to
actually live in an apartment for a long
time because it's not about land in uh
new york it's it's about you know
it's about the space you have in
whatever building so anyways they live
in this building together
you know and steve martin plays like
a old
old sitcom detective like an old like
like kojak or like you know magnum pi
and so he was like this you know big
detective on this show for like however
many seasons and so now he's the sort of
retired actor but you know it's
from old and then martin short plays
this
you know broadway director who's kind of
down on his luck and then selena gomez
is this sort of mysterious
seem to be artist who who's living in
the building also but you know she's the
young one of the group and they're
they're huge fans of
true crime podcasts
so these these are fans of true crime
podcasts and they sort of bond over this
one podcast that
they all listen to and that's how they
sort of like start talking because there
is a murder in their building so someone
gets murdered in their building and then
they decide to start a podcast about
that murder and they're trying to
investigate this murder and so that's
basically what the show is about
yeah the show is about you finding out
who did the murder why they did the
murder and and all the players and it's
actually that part of it is actually
pretty fascinating
it's you know it's it's a little
far-fetched but it's like fun to watch
them deal with it and it's just also fun
to see these people
dealing with their own personal things
too they're actually really great actors
i didn't realize celina gomez was such a
good actor she's doing pretty good my
only thing about selena gomez and it's
just very strange and for the people
that watch this show please comment
about this now
she got a weird speech pattern
now i don't know if she's putting on
this speech pattern as a character
choice
or this is how selena gomez talks i'm
not sure it's very unusual i'm not
saying it's bad okay i'm just saying
it's unusual and if i'm not familiar
with her i don't know if like oh that's
just selena gomez so you got to let me
know if you if you're a selena gomez fan
and you watched her on other things
it's just it's very unusual but she's
actually she's actually doing a great
job with these comedy
giants like these guys are legends man
steve martin and martin short are
legends in the game like you know
they're so funny even to this day at
this age they're still funny there's
just something about them and
like i say i think martin short is just
he's killing it like they they give him
all the funny lines and he delivers them
with style and grace and it is so
freaking funny and selena gomez is
holding her own
like she's like the straight man or
straight woman uh in the thing you know
like these two crazy old guys and she's
just there to give you that love of that
give you that kind of like you know
bland straight line that of what you're
feeling yourself about these old guys
you know so but it's if you have hulu i
i do highly suggest you watch it i think
it's like i said i think it's a very
interesting show it's really it's very
very new it's very it's very different
it's different it's like they make a lot
of artistic choices
oh man like oh i mean is this giving i
don't i don't know if this is a spoiler
or not
well maybe this is a spoiler it's not a
spoiler of the plot guys okay so don't
worry about that
but there is someone deaf
in the show okay
and then they do a entire episode
in silence
you know and it was just
such an interesting creative choice
that i was just like no and i didn't
really like it like i didn't like the
whole thing like like there was a point
where i was like oh they're doing this
you know there was like and then you had
like wrap your brain around it you know
it's kind of like when you watch
something and you don't realize it's a
musical and then all of a sudden it's a
musical and you might be like oh i
wasn't ready for a musical ain't nothing
wrong with it but it's just like your
brain you got to wrap your brain around
it so prepare for that maybe i'm helping
you but you're going to be like ooh i
wonder whatever when that episode comes
you'll be like okay i was ready for this
because riffing with griffin told me to
be ready for it but it's just a very
fascinating choice very artistic choice
very creative choice and it was so
different and as an artist myself as
somebody in the business i i was like oh
that's great i just didn't i didn't just
particularly like it the whole time but
i was like wow what do you do for 25
minutes it's like you know what i mean
like they really went for it and it's
like if they would have done it like if
it was a whole season of that turn it
off but to make an episode choice i
thought that was very it was good it was
very interesting so uh make sure you
check that out so i do i give a a huge
thumbs up i i got to get my own thing
because thumbs up is from siskel and
ebert
what should mine be so let's do a poll
question for that you know what what
should my
uh
thing be you know it should be mustache
up or
i don't know
we have to come up with some kind of
like ratings just a name for my rating
system but for right now i give it five
stars
yeah i think you should watch i think
it's worth watching so take some time
watch it
uh you got the endorsement here from
riffin with griffin
all right next up guys
next up another
really fantastic thing that i watched
was
dune
dune baby the new movie dude i never saw
the original dune it's like let's
actually look that up
original
they're from the 80s i believe it was
um you know i don't know
um i forgot even who was in that movie i
think billy idol was in the movie you
know what i mean yeah it was in
1984. you know 1984
the original here we go let's go to
let's go to the imdb
and look at the original dune
uh where you guys at let's just switch
to screen there we go yeah so the
original dune was in 1984.
um i don't even look at i don't even
recognize some of these actors actors
and actresses that were in the show
um but it was you know i don't know man
the original dune was like super weird i
never understood it it just you know
what i mean it was just one of these
weird psychedelic psychedelic and i was
just too young at the time too in 1984 i
was 12 i think
you know so this
this wouldn't have been the movie for me
so it's just one of those things where
it just went on like you know it was
like okay
see you later dune
you know and then they tried so many
other times to like then they had like
children of dune and then it was another
dune you know they you know they tried
their best to uh oh patrick stewart was
in the original dune i didn't know that
you know they they tried their best to
like make this sucker happen so i don't
know so then like you know this is what
they do there's no original ideas in
hollywood anymore sometimes there's just
a lot of like let's remake or let's do
it again so they did it with this one
with
this dune
and but i gotta tell you man
um this this movie was fantastic and i
saw it in the theater too so i guess
it's getting mixed reviews from some
people but i don't care i'm just telling
you what i thought of it and i just
think i mean this movie was so good man
so it stars this kid
timothy timothy i don't even know how to
say his name timothy chalmette i'm not
even sure what else he's been in let's
look and see
the other movie i've seen him before but
you just like you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's like he's always in artsy fartsy
stuff man you know he was a little woman
he was in beautiful boy
lady bird
call me your name like it's all this
sort of artsy fartsy stuff that he's
been in
um
oh they're in pre-production for dune 2
which is great that's good to hear
uh you know it's always smart so that so
this kid was in uh he's the star you
know and then you know it had oscar
oscar isaac who's a great actor zendaya
i don't know she goes by one name now
she was great jason mamoa was so you
know what every last week i talked about
the show he's on c
he's a he's actually becoming a really
great actor like an action guy but a
really great actor that has depth and
like i believe him you know he's like
such a great hero jason mimosa i like to
call him but jason momoa is he's a
really great actor josh brolin is in
this he's always great as this he's
always the surly old guy you know he's
great in it um
oh man oh dude stellan this guy stellan
skovsgaard whatever he he's he's been in
the marvel universe man he plays a great
villain
you know so it's just a really this guy
this lady rebecca ferguson oh man she's
so tortured in this she's good so
there's a lot of really great
performances
in this um in dune so
yeah so i i i saw this in the movie
theater too i went with my cousin and it
was before a show first of all we went
to this amc in arlington area in this
really nice little area
i've never seen i've never been to that
area before and my cousin she lives in
that area and never been there either
they had like a beer festival outside it
was it was really strange uh you know it
was like they blocked off the street and
there was like all these like beer
places and like uh what you know tents
and everybody had everybody was drinking
beer in the street so they had it
blocked off a certain area but i didn't
understand what there was kids and dogs
and stuff and it was like this beer
festival they had bratwurst and all kind
of stuff and the movie theater was right
there so we went into the movie theater
you know that the movie was at four
o'clock so the movie's at four o'clock
and my first my show was at seven
so i was like i i thought we'd be fine
now it was a two and a half hour movie
it's a long movie it's two hours and 35
minutes man just amc man
they had legit 28 minutes of previews
i'm i'm not exaggerating y'all it was
like 26 minutes of previews and then two
minutes of like amc stuff
you know like they had this nicole
kidman video
that was a couple minutes long
of her talking about you know it was all
dramatic she's in the theater like going
to the movies is a great experience and
blah blah blah and then the whole like
concession stuff and it was 28 minutes
like i love previews i love watching
previews but it got to a point where i
was like well god damn how many previews
are they gonna show and then it started
to be like oh man am i gonna be late for
the show so i had to hit it we were like
six minutes away from the the the draft
house so i said to the i texted the guy
i said don't panic i'm at a movie i will
be there
but yeah we got out of the movie at like
6 55 and we barely made it we i didn't
make it to the beginning of the show but
it didn't matter because it was a guy
opening but anyways
dune
so we saw it in a theater and it was
like a fantastic movie experience like i
haven't wanted to watch a movie a second
time
in a long time
i'm talking about for five years now or
so i would go see a movie and other than
like the marvel stuff you know like i
wanted to see end game again in the
movie theater but like other than
something big like that i haven't
watched a movie where i go oh man i
gotta see this again and this is one of
those movies man so
how do i even explain what dune is about
uh without and there's no spoilers in it
and you can watch it on hbo max by the
way and i think a lot of people are
watching it there but i do suggest even
if you watch it on hbo max
go see this sucker in the movie theater
it's worth it it is such a great movie
experience the sound the cinematography
the the special effects are so seamless
the acting is great
i believed everyone um now it was like
it was like an adult sort of star wars i
think you know because any time you're
out in space and there's planets and
there's an emperor and there's like oh
you know you get sort of a star wars
vibe but it wasn't as childish you know
this isn't for everybody
it's a really great story of like it's
kind of game of thrones meets star wars
uh you know what i mean it's like
family intrigue and politics and magic
and you know you know you know it has
that sort of vibe you know you get sort
of like a jedi sort of thing going on
you get sort of like you know there's
factions fighting against each other
there's families there's you know
families fighting for territory and and
status and you know
you know there's there's evil and they
don't make it so concrete like these are
the bad guys these are the good guys
because you know it's hard to even tell
so you know dune oh they and here's the
thing that they did and the reason why i
want to see it twice is
they had a lot of splaining to do you
know what i mean there was a lot of
explaining to do like when you're
introducing made-up universes okay it's
like you know it's easy to say it's like
if you're doing like some spy movie and
you're going like you know this this
[ __ ] the country is france for instance
we don't need a lot of backstory because
we live in the united we live on on
earth so we we kind of can infer
everything there's common information in
our head so they don't got to go into
all this exposition about like you know
you know europe was founded and blah
blah blah this is why france is france
and you know because then you then when
you get all that information then you'll
be like oh okay i get it so they had to
do a lot of this in dune so the first
like 35 minutes of the movie is kind of
getting us caught up on this is the
universe this is what's been happening
you know hear these people and hear
these people uh you know you get a sense
okay so there's an overall emperor who
you haven't met yet who's kind of like
the galactic empire and they they they
run the whole place and there's like
these families and they have their own
planet and you know you know and it's
sort of like this royal system of like
there's dukes and barons and you know
and
and they're sort of like controlled by
this empire you know and there's like
everybody's got their own planet type of
thing right and so you open up you know
you you learn about this you learn about
this
planet oh i forgot the name of the
planet already this is what i'm saying
well you gotta get all this information
in your head but there's like this
planet that has this um
rare mineral they call it spice
and this
stuff is used for intergalactic travel
so it's very valuable and this is the
one planet i believe you could get this
from apparently you know and it's like a
sand planet it's like you know sand
dunes you know and it's this like really
hard planet that like you know
with weird weather and you know it's
just a hot ass desert the whole planet
you know and there's native people that
live there and you know you're sort of
following what's going on with them and
how they're interacting of course
they're being enslaved by the
the bad people you know because people
you know you know what i mean it's kind
of like avatar you know where you know
the you know the bad the the government
comes in because they want some kind of
mineral and there's like some native
people living there and it's sacred to
them and it's that kind of vibe
so you know and then you learn about
this planet and so they're telling you
the story of like all you know
these people were there enslaving them
not but you know like not treating them
well and then like the emperor told them
to leave and then they have this other
people come and that's this family right
here you know so this kid
i don't know if his name is he's paul uh
he's the star the kid timothy uh and he
you know
you you follow his story he's the main
guy you're following him
you know and he in it and it's like it's
a great story about father and son and
and legacy and and the fighting is good
and you know it's just i don't want to
do i don't want to spoil the movie you
know i think what i'll do you know like
in a few you know maybe a month i'll do
like a whole recap of the movie like i
do but this was a good movie so i don't
like recapping a good movie i like
recapping bad movies because they're so
stupid but this was a really good one
and all the performances were great you
know you're following this kid and
instead right away part one i like that
i looked on imdb and it said they're in
pre-production for part two i just don't
think they've made an announcement but i
think the movie is really doing great
but i don't know if i've done i'm trying
not to spoil it because everybody gets
mad at me when i spoil movies but i do
want to say this is completely worth
watching and especially if you don't
want to pay you already have hbo max
watch it on hbo max but i'm saying to
you i think it's a really great movie
theater experience
i don't know who made the music but it's
like a really riveting music uh
when you're watching these
battles or or just things that are
happening like what like you see this
really grand scene
you know this great cinematography of
this you know made-up universe and
everything you see and they have this
great music that goes with it so i it
was just a really great movie experience
and and i was reminded of why movies are
so
beloved you know like the movie going
experience is great man i had a i had a
big bucket of popcorn and i had my coke
zero and you know what i mean we were
just my cousin and i were just like oh
whispering to each other like oh my god
this is so good i can't believe this is
happening you know it was just one of
those experiences and i'm you know i i'm
just sitting here
i'm glad that we're sort of back to
normal or that this is still an option
uh during these crazy times so if you
haven't gone to a movie yet and you're
looking to go see
a movie
i'm suggesting that you go see dune
um yeah that's really uh all i have to
say about that
um
like i say really great performances man
it was just a really fantastic
movie experience man
let's go to this right now i want to
show you let's go to this little
this little thing
yeah man this guy so good
you know he was great isaac something or
other i mean just a great he was the
father i mean look at some of these
scenes man like it just
from the imdb it was just like you know
epic battles there's jason mamoa he was
like i said he was really good jason
momoa was really good in this movie and
i think that like like oh and uh what's
his name um
uh like the two actors from c are in
this man
oh you got to see this like
[Laughter]
like so the bad guy is this guy and he's
like he's floating a lot
so it was like he's he's very much like
a fat doctor evil
with floating power so there's going to
be a lot of memes and a lot of funny
things people are gonna do about it but
like you know it was it was actually
pretty good
i like that uh here's the kid timothy
who paid paul uh he you know again
you know it's like you get the young
cute actor with the with the justin
bieber hair type of thing you know it's
like this is what we like we like young
people being the stars of stuff but i
like when those young people have some
depth and
soul and they and he really gives a
great performance so all his artsy
fartsy choices that he's made in the
past has led him to combine like a
action movie
big epic big budget action movie with
his
um you know artsy fartsy skills and it
it leads to a very great performance so
i really enjoyed this kid in the movie
and this lady too who plays the mom
um rebecca ferguson oh my gosh she i
really liked i liked her like i liked
her because
she's a mom of you know and she's i'm
not gonna tell you all the stuff that
she's dealing with or her story but like
you could see all that she's dealing
with with her performance without her
saying any words
you know
you know and she's just a great mama
bear performance you know and i really
enjoyed
i really enjoy just watching her and
she's also she's captivating too she's
beautiful and she just really gave a
great uh performance you know and then
uh this one here zendaya zadeh i don't
know how to say her name
she was she's it's weird she's in the
movie and she's not in the movie
but i think that like if they go to part
two she's gonna be huge in that one but
you'll see what i'm talking about when
you watch it you know she was great oh
there he is again and of course brolin
josh brolin is just you know
he's he
he just you believe him as the as the
sort of like sergeant or whatever the
grizzly like you know
grumpy
whoever he always does a great job of
that he did you know and so you know it
really was a lot of epic
battle stuff and and intrigue family
intrigue so it's very good you know if
you're watching on youtube you can see
all these images that i'm showing you
but if you're listening right now i do
recommend you go watch the movie but
like like this is the kind of stuff i'm
talking about they had these really like
great cinematography where like you know
he's holding on to the kid and they're
in this ship and then there's this thing
i'm not gonna tell you what's coming
after them but like you know it just
really looked great on the big screen
you know like the special effects these
days are just so great that that you
can't even see it's like it's so
seamless now so i really enjoyed i
really enjoyed uh this damn thing wait i
i mean look back at this picture
uh is hunt i wonder if hunters is are
they doing a season two of hunters on
prime if they're doing a season two i
gotta check that out because that was
also i should actually review that but
i'm gonna check i hope there is a season
two of that you know i'm i'm learning
this stuff on the fly but uh anyways
guys
wait let me go back to this
uh
boom
uh let's get rachel back on the screen
there we go so yeah man
uh i like to say i recommend dune i want
you to check out um
murder murder in the building i thought
that i thought that was really good uh
so make sure you guys uh check that one
out too
but i don't know um it's just i i think
i'm gonna have a guest next week i
really uh appreciate you guys
um um watching the other podcasts too
you know you don't have to but you know
it's like check out gender gen man i
think it's different you know if you
like me and you're gonna see me
interacting with someone else and we had
we had a great episode we've had dane
cook on
the dane episode was really fun because
it's good to have somebody my age
talking to this young kid about the
things that we like and you know how
technology has changed our lives and all
that kind of stuff so we had a really
great discussion and then we had meghan
trainor and her brother on and we had a
really great discussion about mental
health and therapy and all that kind of
so that was a good one right there and
um you know but i got i'm having i'm
getting some more people to come on that
one and mine so make sure you uh check
that
out
so guys
we did it
another fantastic episode of riffing
with griffin this one was short and
sweet i appreciate you guys being here
make sure you check me out on eric
griffin gaming that's daily i'm always
on twitch uh you know so if you want to
be a part of that community on saturdays
most saturdays i try to game with the
fans i do custom matches of war zones
and i'm going to start playing some
other games too but make sure you come
check that out america gaming and just
thanks for being here man
i appreciate like i said earlier in the
show i appreciate all the love i
appreciate the people that come up to me
at the shows who are really making a
difference in my life personally because
you're coming to my show you're spending
money and you're telling me hey i
appreciate you you're the ones that i
should focus more on and i really do
appreciate you so this is a celebration
of you guys so thanks for that
and uh you know i'm still going this is
episode 157 so
let's keep building let's keep growing
and
i appreciate you and thanks for watching
with griffin and i will see you next
week rip in griffin